那么在上层逻辑呢
它也需要一个类似的封装
就是把整个一个渲染的绘制的这样一个命令
以及它涉及到的所有的相关的信息收集起来
形成一个通用的数据集数数据结构
然后同时把它转换成hi层面的命令的调用
那么这个数据结构呢就是我们今天关注的重点
我们了解一下它是大概长什么样子的
提供了哪些函数以及怎么收集它的
那这个类就是我们现在看到的这个
F major command
就是一个max的JW的一个命令
那么我们一条渲染管线
一个一个绘制渲染的命令
它是要涉及到哪些东西呢
第一是整个渲染管线的所有的设置
也就是我们常说的pipeline day
比如说里面设置它的光栅化一些啊
STL啊之类的设置对吧
然后还有着色器
顶点着色器
像素折射器以及它们的输入对吧
这些信息
那么很明显我们看一下它的成员变量
那第一个C的BING很明显就是着色器相关的
第二个这个就是顶点顶点的相关数据
然后这个就是索引的数据
index buffer看名字都很明显了哈
就是具体我们比如说你可以进去看一下
它很明显就是呃这是一个数组
一个顶点的input vertex的数组
数组里面其实是什么
其实就是一个hi的buffer
就是一个顶点的buffer
还有它对应的呃
所以以及偏移是吧啊
这个这种这种我们以后见到他就点进去看一下
他其实都是比较简单的一些数据结构而已
好回过头来
也就是说这个max jokman
首先已经有了着色器顶点输入的信息
然后第二个呢就是pd
当然了他做了很多操作
他这里加了一个id
但是你不用管它具体的那个优化的细节
它反正就代表了PAPI对所有的信息
然后能保存起来
然后能get出来就可以了
那pi的相关的信息
然后还有一些三角形相关的信息是吧
三角形相关的信息
然后还有一些什么DL啊之类的值
那么比如说三角形的类型
那么这个数据结构上
它就已经包含了整一个渲染所需要的
所有的数据
就是把它收集起来
实际上在这在U1引擎里面的渲染
它其实就是一步步的把它收集吧
比如说你整一个场景
一个关卡里面有很多角色
角色模型是吧啊
有各种各样的组件
它最终就是会把他这些东西收集起来
然后呃最终构造成这一堆这样子的
Max joke man da
还有一些其他的不一定全部都是max drake man
比如说你调试的时候
你要画一条直线
它可能就直接划过去了
它就不一定哈
当然也也也可能是这个我们后面看到了再说哈
那么大大体上所有的那些静态模型
动态模型包括骨骼那些呃模型啊是吧
角色里面的那它都会最终先收集起来生成它
那么就是对应的这些信息好
那么我们看它一个函数
就可以了解它的那个东西呢
它这里有一个最后的一个提交
就是这个submit draw
就是说你收集收集那么多信息
记录在这个类的对象里面的时候
那么它最终一定要把它转译成HI层面的那个
命令调用
那么就是具体掉了这个SWED
那我们可以跳到它函数里面去看
这是一个静态静态成员变函数哈
它不是一个类的成员函数
是一个静态static啊
就是就是它是一个STATA
但它实际上就是把把这个max comment传进去哈
那他其实提供了一个这样的方法
那它其实很简单
它就分成两个步骤
第一个步骤呢就是一个begin调一个做的begin
第二个就是做an
那么做begin呢其实就是设置设置所有的东西
and呢就是那个真正的那个draw index
那他为什么要这样区分呢
就是有时候他不一定说我
A就是直接调RHI的JOINDEX
这个就就没什么好说的
就是把收集到的所有的参数传进去
然后就掉就行了
没有了好
那这个就是N哈
下面也一样
他只是分不同的情况做一些分类哈
但是每个分类其实都是做哈
要不就是做这个delete的方法而已哈
啊这个N就是做
那么真正的设置就是在这个begin里面
那假设我已经收集到所有的信息了
它其实就是对应的去转换
每一个HI层面的信息
那转换要哪些东西呢
那就是pipeline day是DCS呃
顶点输入
然后还有着色器相关的什么uniform buffer啊
sample啊
SRV啊
呃纹理图片texture之类的
他就是把这些东西全部收进去
我们看一步步来好
那这个字就是max o man传进来的
所以他从max o man里面拿出来的那个pipeline id
刚才我们说的是pipeline id
但是实际上他做只是内部做了一些优化
但是它实际上就是里面蕴含着一个pipeline day
所包含的所有的信息
其实就是这个现在只是把它get出来
反正这个啪啪拉丁能get出来就OK了
那它里面的什么信息呢
可以稍微的去浏览一点啊
这个pi对这个INITIALIZER
它其实你看他的这个成员变量就大概知道了哈
呃我们看一个全全部的OK
那大概就是这些啊
对于他绑定的那个着色器的相关的信息
然后blank st rurier stay过大话啊
深度检测模板测试是吧
还有一些sampler
然后还有一些呃三角形的类型
然后还有一些这些什么相关的参数
那其实就是这些pd
还有这些啊
这个这个是什么
就是它我们可以可以浏览一点
呃你看这里包括顶点的声明
顶点的着色器
像素着色器
然后还有其他的什么match max啊
其他的
然后还有他的用到的那个resource对吧
所以呢就是它代表了整个渲染管线的
所有的相关的数据都存储起来
那么就是这个papi day
那么它就是把它拿出来
然后就去设置它
那就是这个那把这个pipeline day拿出来之后
就是这样子apply进去呃
这个注意这个这个只是把它呃是什么意思呢
就是说呃这个command linux里面的那种呃
缓存起来的信息填充到这个pipeline day里面去哈
就是因为因为有一些就是当前的状态哈
就是当前这个I就command里面有一些什么状态
就是把它拿出来哈
好那最后呢就是什么呢
就是呃这个就是设置进去set pist
那跳进去呃
就是调这个hi的pipeline st里面
就是具体的那些什么过拉菲拉pad
就直接掉到那个context里面的了
那就调到平台里面的真正的设置这个PAPI了哈
这是第一部分
第二部分呢当然还有什么呃
设置那些模板测试是吧
DAL的值是吧
也不但同时也把它搞缓存下来
然后呢
然后还要设置什么
设置顶点的一些相关的数据吧
那你看一个for循环
一个for循环
把所有的顶点输入都遍历一遍
然后set这个stream source是吧
然后最后这个这个也是设置一些呃
SHADER相关的东西哈
那他就根据不同的CD呃
比如说呃顶点的或者是像素的话就match的
然后把顶点的相关的东西设置进去
没有了嗯
这是一个在上层逻辑的抽象啊
它其实跟跟我们IHI层面
或者是DX12里面的那个层面
我们记得哈
上一次我们讲那个DX12里面
它其实也缓存了一套
就说当你真正调那个HI那些什么设置的时候
它其实是放在那个一个cs里面的一个state
一个缓存里面的哈
真正的时候他才一次性全部调用哈
我们上一节上一节的那个视频讲了哈
他就是类似就是要把所有的东西收集起来哈
就是papi day那顶点输入缓存
然后包括呃什么uniform buffer
sir v啊
texture啊这些全部啊
他这也是类似
所以呢这个这个max jokman其实它很简单
但是呢他我们要要要了解它
就是我们这个类是非常重要的
它在上层逻辑是提供了这样一个封装的实现
也就是说在上层逻辑就怎么样呢
每一次渲染就负责收集信息
生成这样子的max9孔慢
然后这个max9孔慢
再通过他的这个submit draw的函数
就把它真正的转换成RHI层面的指令
那么它就是实现这样一个功能好
那这个类并不会并不会太复杂哈
你看下面这些函数都是一些很常见的
就是不长了哈
那么整整体而言
就是看它的成员变量就可以了哈
了解一下他成员变量
熟悉这些具体的数据结构
然后他就是一个小米做
然后就分begin and begin呢就是设置状态
设置着色器
设置顶点输入设置uniform buffer
设置一堆N呢就是直接就JOINDEX
就是发起那个JD的命令的的那个调用
全部都是转换成2+2层面的相关信息
好这个就是max jo这个command的一个类的重要性哈
那具体他是怎么收集转换呢
他还不是直接收集它
并不是说比如说我们上层蓝图所说的那个呃
比如说有一个primate component
那并不是就就每次就就把它转换成这个
max jokman哈
那它中间还有一个过程呢
是先转换成一个啊max batch这样的一个概念哈
OK那它就是是什么呢
我们看一下啊
等一下就是呃这个东西怎么来的
我们看这个max o man怎么来的
有一个叫bill max jokman的函数
OK我找一下
bill max周口吗
OK就是它好
这是一个模板类的函数
那大概的流程呢就是会在中间某个过程呃
根据搜集到的这个max batch的数据
把它变成max jo min
很明显这个函数就是根据输入去创建max jokmin
那么他根据哪些输入呢
就是这个这个也是一个非常重要的数据结构
这个max batch
那么它大体的流程就是第一步
会在某个地方收集所有当前所有整个场景
所有的四口
所有的那个
还还有可能还先做一些可见性的测试
然后把他们收集的那个prompt
这些信息全部收集起来
然后生成这个max batch
这是第一步
第二步就是把这个max batch去生成这个max jocm
他为什么这样子的长
这这样子去实现呢
呃这个也是有一部分历史原因的
在很早以前可能是由于4.20以前甚至更早
我这个我就没有具体研究过啊
大概反正在大概在4.20之前是没有这个max
可慢了
还是反正很假
具体哪个版本之前
就是后面才才又才引入这个max joke man哈
所以呢他前前期呢就是先收集这个max batch后
然后再做这个max batch
转换成max o man这样一个类似
那么中间转换就是这个B那build也很简单啊
这个build也很简单
它其实就是那第一他他搞了一个shift的
因为有很一个batch里面可以有很多个呃
科曼代表了很多个不同的
那么他先收集一个公共的
然后再加那个那收集公共的
就比如说这些什么是单手啊
普普及的三角形的状态呀
以及这些PAPI
也就是说它都是类似的
所以他先搞一个share的数据结构哈
真正实际上创建呢就是在这个下面哈
就上上半部分呢就是收集通用的
比如说pipeline day是吧
你看这些收集到的pipeline day
然后还有这些顶点的工厂啊
顶点工厂这些都是公共的
然后就是他先存储在这个里面
然后到时候就复制哈
实际上真正的收集的是这个下面这个for循环
然后他真正的去这里面这个呃这个max ma
那他收集到的所有max max在一个JOLIX里面哈
这些反正我们先不用管它存在哪里
我们知道有肯定有某个地方是个数组
或者是一个什么啊
他就就是就是一个数组
就是这里才真正的把它添加进去
只是它前面的这个血
就相当于是一些相同的参数
直接去拷贝过来而已
就是以他为模板
先创建一个max ma
然后下面就收集一些大每个每个不同的哈
那那所以不要不要不误看代码的时候看
了解一下他大理的思路就OK了
好那其实就是从这个max batch里面去搜
变成这个max做空吗
那这个max batch为什么要一个for循环呢
是因为我们看一下这个max batch的
一个大体的数据结构
一个max batch呢它其实是代表了一组一组数据
就是它是一个数组
它是一个数组
就是说它有多个max batch的元素
虽然很多情况下
一个max batch可就是只有一个element
很多情况下其实就是一个
但是从代码的角度来说
我们说一个beats
这个max batch里面是由一组element的一组元素的
那么这一组元素呢
它是呃共享了这些啊顶点数的工厂
然后共享了一组的材质
就是material材质的啊
还有一些相关的相关的意思的东西
也就是说这他不是说随意的
就是说它代表了一组有着相同的顶点的工厂的
以及有着相同的材质的一种元素
一种模型max的元素
所以呢因为他们共享了一些相同的顶点工厂
所以我们在这个build里面的函数里面呢
它就是先收集通用的那pauline day
顶点工厂要先找出这个
然后在下面的这个for循环
在下面这个for循环
以这个SHCON为模板去创建出一个
其实哎进去就是创建一个呃
就是他
那这个传进来的只是一个模板
就是把它转换一下诶
是他吗
不是不是这个是K的嗯
我们看这个
买进去
然后new一个搞一个new的出来对吧
你看那这个就应该是个数组嘛对吧
是一个数组
然后哎一个元素
以这个先以这个公共的血的添加进去
然后把它返回出来
然后继续修改
那就是这样的啊
所以呢他其实就是一个max batch呢
里面有一组一个数组的element
那么对于每一个element
它就要创建一个这个max jokman
然后再收集这个具体的一些相关的信息
那就是下面的这些什么什么一些visible啊
相关的那个一个参数
然后对于这个SHADER的一些设置对吧
点点vertex shader
pixel c的就match c的所有的信息
然后呃还有一些三角形相关的信息
然后最后finalize
就是完成了这个创建
他其实就是嗯把这个max batch的
把收集到的一堆max batch
然后转成max jokman
因为max jokman才真正的max joke
你可以这么理解
max jokman就是负责把收集到的信息
转换成RHI的渲染命令
而max batch呢只是提实现了提供了额
代表了这个模型
它的材质
它的顶点的数据
索引的数据以及相关的信息
就说它代表的是这样子啊
嗯最后呢那这个max batch又是怎么来的呢
那流程呢大概就是呃
有一个game的一个收集的过程
它大概就是g a t h e r dynamic
mesh对
啊这个类
那这个就是比较熟悉的
就是看这个类的名字
就是场景渲染了render哈
那么在场景整个render的时候
就会去搜集这个max bench
收集完这个max这个max bench
然后就会掉刚才那个去B那个max jokman
Max jokman
最后就会在某个合适的时机
把它转换成i hi层面的那个命令好
那这个收集呢就是真的在一个pass里面去收集
所以这个类这个RENDERER里面是有很多子类的哈
比如说我们常见的平时经常听到的什么base pass啊
是吧很多
那么就去继承它
去实现它
那么这个就是代表了去收集max batch的
那么我们现在收集max batch有什么信息啊
我们有整个场景的信息
我们有整个四口view的信息
以及那这个是global的一个顶点缓存
索引缓存
还有一些什么其他的缓存
还有这个三角形的一些mask
那它其实很简单
它它这里呢就是有一个correct
就是收集器
这个就是max element的收集器
就是最终收集通过它去收集
然后生成那个mah batch
那我们看一下
浏览一下这个correct
这个收集器里面的一个一个数据哈
你看嗯就是这么一堆数组
它就是有一组max batch
然后还有它相关的什么LEL文的信息
这是个数组的数组
然后还有那些什么
它每一个元素对应的一些什么呃数量啊
还有一些这个呢这个simple greater呢就是做什么呢
就是我们在做debug的时候
经常你要在场景里面画一条直线啊
或者是画一个点啊
或者是那种就是不是不是常规的那种呃模型的
而是那种简单的直线啊
点线面这种东西哈
它就是放在这里面嗯
然后还有一些信物啊
这些就还有这些材质
那简单来说你就关注这两个
现在我们先关注两个太多东西了
我们这也就是说一个收集器correct
就是负责收集全部的这个mah batch
那他怎么收集呢
好我们刚才看了啊
我们现在对这个印象
这个correct max element platter
就是有一组max batch
那它其实就是要在这个这里面
去搜集所有的信息
生成它里面的那个数组的信息
那首先呢就是首先KOREAKOREA就是清空
然后呢他就是怎么样呢
就是在下面那这里还会做一个可见性的判断啊
就是如果你是不可见的
他其实就不收集了
他就剔除掉那些看不见的那看不见的因素
当然不需要渲染的
是不是
这里呢就做了一个这个view max可用来判断哈
然后然后先设计先设置这个PROMPTY的信息
然后呢其实就是在这里面去这个函数
我们跳进去
那这个前前面的就是说对于每一个每一个呃
三角形的数据的数据也不是三角形
就是在这个跳进去哦
它是一个它是一个虚函数
我们说它它要在这个子类去实现啊
我们看一个简单的base pass的还是怎么样的
看这个吧
对随便看一个就是这个policy policy
那就是也是一个类似一个基类似
然后子类去实现它
那么这个get里面呢就是负责
你看我们有view的信息是吧
传一来我们就是要收集这个
收集到这个greater里面去
不同的pass他用了不同的那个PY
然后具体的实现是不有点不同
但是它大体的实现都是类似的
大体的实现就是类似的
就是去收集那些相关的信息哈
就是便利便利这个view遍历所有的view
那虽然很多时候可能view只有一个哈
但是先遍历
然后看这个JOJOBATCH
那第一先a local一个max batch
就是先增加一只
增加一个max batch
然后呢实际是我们刚才还提到
为什么
其实没很多时候
一个max batch里面就是一个只有一个element啊
大多数时候它就是只有一个哈
那他直接把他第零个拿出来
然后去设置哈什么
那不会就是顶点啊
这个是索引
这个是三角形的信息
这些是呃VERTIC的信息是吧
还有什么还有模型的信息
这个是什么WIFI
就是是不是网格是吧
然后顶点的factory
然后它的材质material的信息就是把它收集起来
然后带进去
仅此而已
那它就是遍历所有的view
把所有的便利哈
注意哈
便利所有的will
然后收集到那个creator里面
那个是个子类的实现啊
这个是个子类的实现
这个proxy
这个same proxy它有很多各种各样的指针
我们随便挑一个它的类似的
就是中间它有很多特殊的操作
但中间的核心就是把那些相关的mesh的顶点啊
相关的信息顶点工厂是吧
收集到那个max batch里面去
那就是他这个SYLLA
后面我们还要更加认真的去看这些SEMENLA哈
但因为其他的这些信息太多太多了
我们不能一下子全部看了
我们今天主要是建立一个大体的流程
我们今天要熟悉的是那个max joke m
那个是在上层逻辑里面
对整个渲染命令的一个封装
然后我们要了解两个过程
第一个过程就是在SLLER里面
他负责去第一步收集所有的max batch
那他是通过这个correct里面去收集的
就是它里面是一个max space的数组
然后收集完
然后我们通过那个BW函数把max batch变啊
创建根据max batch去创建max周口吗
这样一个流程就完成了呃
从场景收集各种各样的呃
网格模型的信息先收集起来
然后变成一组命令
然后最后转移成i hi的流程
它好
今天我们就呃没看那么细啊
先了解这个大点的流程
我们有了这个基础
我们后面就接着看一个个pass怎么实现好
今天就到此为止